Stephen Colbert and the formerly
glamorous Hollywood former elite turned
out Sunday night to grab the lowest
hanging fruit and shriek about Donald
Trump for two hours at the Emmys then
YouTube's Red Bill Black
The Daily wires Jacob Barry and his
eminence Paul Bois joined the panel of
deplorable z' to discuss Trump's first
speech at the UN the imminent rapture
which a Christian numerologist predicts
will occur in five days hide your kids
hide your wife and the st. Louis Blues
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show now listen we always
try to be as mean as possible to
Marshall on this show it's one of our
favorite aspects of the show and one of
the reasons we wake up every morning but
today today is Marshalls birthday I
don't know if you know that happy
birthday Marshall he's 14 this year
you've won for starting high school or
plus good luck man you're gonna be great
good luck trying out for the football
team and all that he is gonna be great
that little baby face Marshall Benson
happy birthday we got to get right into
this I had actually I watched the Emmys
yesterday because Clavin made me and for
that he will have to answer to st. Peter
Sunde and I before that I had seen
mother which we'll talk about a little
bit more later mother is basically two
hours of Jennifer Lawrence being
tortured I found the Emmys much more
torturous than mother then watching
Jennifer Lawrence go through hell
literally so here let's let's begin at
the very beginning here is Stephen
Colbert's opening
[Music]
turn on and channel well except the news
cuz troubles aren't so trouble
in HD
[Music]
the world's a little better on TV that
is the thesis here and it's kind of
frustrating that Colbert is such a good
performer he's a great showbiz performer
and all he does is he's just a hack the
whole time he's just telling he's super
such a race Michael it is it's a huge
waste of talent
and so that's the contention everything
is better on TV well is it let's see how
the world looks through the lens of TV
let's kick it off who are you rooting
for tonight that is its array that is a
youtuber turned into a TV star and in
this world she is representing the black
people who are deeply oppressed by
Hollywood black people cannot get a
break in Hollywood and so we have to
have racial solidarity one can only
imagine if I said I'm rooting for all
the white people in in the Emmys but
that is what she's saying and so is it
reality absolutely not ethnically this
is the most diverse Emmys that has ever
been had from the performers to the
presenters last year was also quite
diverse
it was so ethnically diverse meaning
there were so many minorities in
particular black actors there that the
hashtag Emmy is so black actually
started trending last night in response
to the Oscars so white claims of a
couple years ago so reality reality
seems a whole lot better than the world
of TV in that instance but let's keep
going Stephen Colbert what else have you
got
[Music]
treason and right before that Julia
louis-dreyfus accuses Donald Trump of
sympathizing with Nazis so in the world
according to TV Donald Trump is a Nazi
and a traitor now I think separately one
might imply the other but he is
separately a Nazi and a traitor now in
reality of course Donald Trump has
repeatedly disavowed Nazis and the
handful of neo-nazis who apparently
support his campaign by comparison
Democrats never have to disavow antifa
or black live matters
black lives matter riots that have
occurred in cities across the country
and those people who support them they
never have to acknowledge it on the
Russia story in the treason story even
Van Jones a far left winger and
commentator and political analysis says
that the Russia story is quote a nothing
burger but of course nobody with two
brain cells to rub together would think
that Donald Trump is a Manchurian
Candidate for Russians in the world of
TV is a Nazi and a traitor in reality
he's just some guy it's not a big deal
speaking of traitors here is Jane Fonda
giving her little speech to the Emmys
last night back in 1980 in that movie we
refuse to be controlled by a sexist
egotistical lying hypocritical bigot
and interment in 2017 we still refuse to
be controlled by a sexist
[Applause]
where's the puke bucket I need the puke
bucket virtue it's tremendous it's it's
sickening me all of the virtue signaling
now that for those who are either
listening or who couldn't get a good
glimpse that woman who was speaking is a
traitor that woman is an actual traitor
Jane Fonda who aided and abetted our
enemies during Vietnam while they were
killing and imprisoning and torturing
American soldiers she sat on top of
anti-aircraft guns and took photos
anti-aircraft guns simulating shooting
down American planes that's what that
woman and she's saying that in this
country Donald Trump is a sexist
misogynistic bigot who's pushing
everybody around who's pushing you
around Jane Fonda nobody is pushing you
around but perhaps somebody should
because this traitor to her country this
seditious actress gets to give absurd
speeches lambasted the president wrongly
lambasted the president slander hang him
on national television nobody's pushing
her around nobody's stopping her from
doing that unfortunately perhaps but
that's the world of TV in the world of
TV in the world of imagination then
president Trump is a tyrant who is who
is oppressing everybody including
traitors like Jane Fonda now apparently
we're not living in such authority rien
times at least chance the rapper shows
up to finally bring a little levity and
to entertain us just like Stephen
Colbert promised right wrong I'm just
kidding he came out and just gave
another stupid political speech so
chance the rapper from what I could
understand from his rap performance
asked one why cops on television shows
aren't convicted as murderers why men
with psychological disorders like
transgenderism cannot serve in the
military openly and he insists that we
DVR our televisions so that we can go
and protest Donald Trump by the way this
attack came within the first two minutes
of the broadcast this was chance the
rapper so at least we can hope at least
we can hope that the big awards for the
night will make good on that promise of
light-hearted fun the everything's
better on TV right right isn't that no
absolutely wrong here's what's one I was
asleep before
that's how we let it happen when they
slaughtered Congress we didn't wake up
when they blame terrorists and suspended
the Constitution we wake up the neighbor
[Music]
my name is Offred I had another name
ladies I have to let you go long now
yeah I'm sorry I fell asleep during that
trailer as I did through every single
episode of that tedious and pedantic
show which Norma Donald rightly called
subpar science 5e trash it was an it was
it won everything of won Best Drama Best
Actress Best Supporting Actress a couple
other awards we do need to clarify this
was in the same category as the crown it
was oh my gosh it was the crown it beat
out stranger things it beat out
Westworld this was a year of good shows
unbelievable this was a year of good
shows and they want and the reason that
Handmaid's Tale 1 it really is not a
good show it's poorly written it's
poorly conceived the acting is fine I
suppose it's absurdly slow you really
can watch it and maintain any interest
but the reason it won is because Donald
Trump is living rent-free in all of
their heads in the Hollywood and so they
had to give it to the show to send a
message to send a message about the
alleged oppression right so in that show
the the women Elisabeth Moss they're
living in a world in which women are
subjugated by radical Christians now
this is ironic because in our world
today the only place where women are not
subjugated isn't traditionally Christian
nations but if the show had any guts
they would portray a female oppression
in in a Muslim world they would portray
female oppression in a world where there
are consequences to making such claims
but of course they can't do that so they
have to make it about radical Christians
oppressing women when I look around in
reality that does not appear to be the
case so that's the world according to TV
in that world Trump gets pretty negative
coverage you might say obviously the
coverage from the Emmys but there was a
Harvard University study that showed
that CNN and NBC gave Trump 93% negative
coverage 93% now to put that in
perspective that same study showed that
Barack Obama got 41% negative coverage
George W Bush 57% negative coverage and
Bill Clinton 60% negative coverage
because of all of the sex scandals
but Donald Trump 93% now what about
reality how does reality look in reality
the economy is growing there was
accelerated economic growth during
Trump's first full quarter the White
House is repealing the unconstitutional
executive amnesty and possibly
addressing it by legislation there are
stronger lobbying bands for ex White
House employees than we've seen in
recent memory
there is the repeal of one mandate
forcing taxpayers to fund Planned
Parenthood another one forcing taxpayers
to fund abortions overseas looks like
good news to me major reduction in
regulations and delays in our energy
sector to get the economy going again
some reports show that there have been
16 regulations repealed for every new
regulation added there's a decline in
illegal immigration since Donald Trump
was inaugurated and we have a Supreme
Court justice who respects the
Constitution seems to me like everything
is worse on TV let's bring on our panel
to discuss we're very lucky making her
debut on a michael no-show panel of
deplorable we have Candace Owens better
known by her YouTube name red pill black
Candace thanks for being here we have
the Daily wire Jacob Airy and from
Lepanto live we have His Eminence Paul
wah now before we begin I should be fair
there was one moment of levity during
the telecast that was when Sean Spicer
made a surprise appearance and here he
is so it was a knock on Trump but it was
actually a pretty funny moment you know
it was a little it was a little
bipartisan at least they had a
Republican kind of making fun of himself
and having a nice little moment but of
course Hollywood in the mainstream media
hate it
CNN ran the headline today quote why did
the Emmys help Sean Spicer rebrand the
Huffington Post ran an angry viewers are
in no mood to laugh at Sean Spicer zemi
jokes and the Washington Post democracy
dies and darkness said Spicer's yucky
cameo at the Emmys that is why we can't
have nice things
Hollywood used to be glamorous and now
it's crass and vulgar Paul bois should
Sean Spicer have shown up was it a nice
moment or was he sucking up to Hollywood
limousine leftists I mean I agree with
the spirit of the act it's fun it's Joe
at the end of the day this is Hollywood
they're not there they're not gonna go
oh yeah that's so funny Spicer's
laughing at himself they're just gonna
laugh in that moment and then go back to
just being mean-spirited and bashing him
you know behind his back and that's why
Colbert later in the night made that
joke against Spicer I forgive it exactly
what he said so I mean it's just I don't
agree with sucking out two people that
just basically want to punch you in the
face red pill black gone are the days of
Bob Hope what is made Hollywood so
leftist and so screechie in just the
last few years honestly I don't know I
think it's the first time ever we're
seeing what it looks like when these
spoiled toddlers don't get what they
want and they didn't get what they
wanted who they wanted in the White
House and now we have to endure this
super long four year hopefully eight
year wine that doesn't seem to be going
away and it's when you watch the show
it's like they're just in this echo
chamber laughing at themselves and they
just can't get enough of themselves they
have no idea what's going on outside in
the real world I see that and you bring
up a great point which is that it's all
about the presidential election we saw
all of this after George Bush won the
presidency you had Michael Moore ruining
the Oscars and making stupid speeches
and it just seems to be when they get
their way then they basically behave and
when they don't get their way then they
have to ruin every bit of fun and
entertainment that we can ask for out of
Hollywood
Jakub right the whole show was about
Trump the entire thing I mean I I pulled
out a handful of clips I could have
shown the whole to our telecast isn't
that exactly what Trump wants doesn't he
want the attention doesn't he want to
live rent-free in their head and if so
why do they give him what he wants I
think it's just part of their bubble
right so they think we're just going to
keep hammering they because they expect
Trump to act like george w bush so you
know he's going to be passive he's going
to ignore it because you know President
Bush thought the president should be
above all this Hollywood criticism and
but so they're shocked when Trump just
goes after them you can tell their
feelings were very hurt when he totally
ignored them on Twitter that was the
best part of this whole thing
he is so widely especially on Twitter
and speaking of Donald Trump driving
people crazy president Trump has just
given his first speech to the UN this
morning and he claimed in typical
trumpian fashion that the organization
that's been around for 72 years has
quote tremendous potential which I love
now we have to talk about this it's a
great story you can learn about all of
these things you can learn about the
rapture you can hear about mother and
why all the reviewers are getting mother
wrong but you can't do it right now you
have to do it at the Daily wire calm so
we have to say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube thank you for everyone who's
already a subscriber if you're a
subscriber or you want to become a
subscriber go to daily wire.com right
now it's only $10 a month $100 a year
you get me you got the under flavin show
you get the Ben Shapiro show I know what
you're thinking so what so what well
that's what I have to say to that the
leftist tears tumblr can be yours with
an annual subscription now this tumblr I
had this last night next to my
television set
it was overflowing I'm gonna I'm gonna
have floor damage because of all the
leftist tears that were pouring out of
my screen now you need the best vessel
on the market to carry leftist tears as
well
this is absolutely indestructible it
will survive the rapture that is being
predicted for five days from now
so go over to daily wire comm get yours
keep your leftist here's hot or cold
always salty and delicious and we'll be
right back
[Music]
so I could not love president Trump's UN
insult any more as far as I can tell the
UN is an organization where we invite
the worst people on earth to come to our
best city we pay for the lion's share of
the whole thing they give speeches
trashing us and telling us how terrible
we are for a few days and then they go
back to their countries and oppress
their own citizens so President Trump is
taking a harder line with them red pill
black why do we tolerate the UN we
shouldn't I have absolutely no idea why
we've ever tolerated the UN and I think
that this is sort of what Trump excels
at this is what sort of got to go behind
him in the first place is that he's
willing to not play this PC role and
he's willing to call stuff out and the
UN has needed to be called out for a
very long time there waste of time there
waste of money and there are waste of
resources and they do absolutely nothing
they accomplish nothing I couldn't have
said it better myself
Paul wha tell red pill black why she's
wrong is there any role for the UN
period or at least is there any role in
Donald Trump's America the American that
he promised us I mean my opinion of the
UN is simply that I think it's good as
an idea to give people a neutral forum
countries just come and debate their
grievances and that's it as far as
everything that it does organizationally
law around the world it's a complete
disaster and all of that should be
disbanded but in terms of the idea of it
okay let's have a forum for countries
you know this country is mad at this
country okay let's let them talk it out
and debate it okay fine but other than
that it's it's worthless and maybe how
about they just keep their mouth shut
how about these awful dictators and
these terrible human rights abusers keep
their mouths shut and stop telling us
how to run our country which is the
greatest force of national good in the
history of the world who knows Jacob
conservatives don't like the UN
generally speaking the left loves the UN
doesn't matter how many times you share
them the UN has been ineffective
it has not established World Peace it's
not able to really push any consequences
on to people who are abusing their own
citizens but the left nevertheless loves
it they at least love the theory of the
UN why is that I think it's because it
represents what they want you know it's
John Lennon's Imagine right imagine if
there were no countries you know is that
Donald Trump singing imagine but no in
all seriousness no it's it's their
vision of a perfect world it doesn't
matter how evil you are it doesn't
matter that your country abuses human
rights they still want you to be able to
come and talk it out because we're all
good on the inside all of us are you
know who cares if it works in practice
does it work in theory that's the real
question in theory the UN might be fine
but in reality it's a complete waste of
time now most importantly we have to get
to Armageddon the end is nigh a
self-described Christian researcher
named David Meade predicts that it will
all end in five days Jacob will you be
hiding your kids and your wife no this
happen any time there's an eclipse
anytime there's a Blood Moon anytime
there's this this there's this
constellation appearing these Kooks come
out come out of the closet and they're
like oh look we have the date hate to
break it to you Matthew 24:36 says no
one knows the day or the hour of
Christ's second coming not even the
angels of heaven not even not even David
Mead the Christian researcher in America
and Jesus even goes a step further and
says I don't even know only God the
Father knows so I think I think that
this is just gonna all blow over just
like the last guy and the guy before him
it no one knows the day or the hour and
when it comes we won't be ready for it
more than likely oh ye of little faith
you know the metaphor that comes to mind
whenever we talk about this when
Christians come out of the Woodworks to
predict is a lot like Leo Batman's
batarangs where he's just gonna keep
throwing batarangs at the round chariot
I think in it they're gonna say first
try
tell you he was 14 or did I tell you he
was 14 Bob wah Jacob makes a very good
point out of that day or hour no man
knows not even the angels of heaven only
God the Father why is it that this guy
missed the message why do some kooky
Protestant sects always insist on
predicting the end of the world well as
a Catholic Michael I have my own
perspective on this but out of charity
I'll withhold that mostly it's because
what you have is these individual
religious leaders and they're reading
into scripture and they have absolutely
no outside authority to give them any
sort of checking balances on what
they're reading and they read it and
then they come up with their own weird
ideas about you know when the end of the
world is gonna come and then they get
followers to follow them and it always
ends with people disappointed and sad I
mean the last big one was in 1844 with
yeah you know the Millerites you know
just basically another william miller
and paul walkin you confirm are you
speaking ex cathedra when did you make
that statement about the the end of the
world predictors I am speaking as
someone who believes in such humility
such humility from His Eminence
red pill black I don't think it's just
the Christians who were predicting the
end of the world
I think it is the American left and I
think you saw it last night during that
Emmy Awards telecast they every single
thing is a sign of the end of the world
for them now are you very famously to
borrow your own phrase took the red pill
and completely change your mind what
makes that happen you know it was a ton
of things but it was mainly I always say
I was force-fed the the red pill I ended
up in a situation where the left press
was trying very hard to smear me when I
stumbled upon an Internet lie which was
the gamergate non scandal that they made
up support Hillary Clinton and I openly
tweeted about it and I got attacked by
the left and once you actually see that
these corporations are these news
organizations are really just businesses
and Jeff Bezos outright purchased the
Washington Post for the sake of smearing
people and taking down business
in building other businesses up you
can't unsee it so there's really done a
terrible job with wopo too I mean that
thing yeah it used to be pretty bad but
it's unreadable it's yeah it really is
it's so bad it's but you know I have no
regrets about being read Phil I love it
and I'm just happy that I get to spread
the knowledge to other people in the
black community it's amazing that it was
it was an entre versi that did it for
you it was one of these things about
video games it wasn't a major political
issue it was something personal where
you thought I don't quite agree with the
politics on this right exactly and
listen everything happens for a reason
it was pretty crazy falling down the
rabbit hole at first and realizing that
everybody that you thought was like a
white supremacist you know it's actually
like on your side there are a few white
supremacists yeah there are some Hillary
says yeah 66 million of them I'm not so
sure yeah
well then yeah speaking of race
relations and people who are behaving
because they haven't had any red pills
st. Louis residents hate to see that
Evening Sun go down because that's when
the rioters have been attacking police
flipping trash cans and breaking windows
on the streets of st. Louis over the
acquittal of Jason Stockley a white cop
on trial for killing 24-year old Anthony
Lamar Smith a young black man now Smith
had apparently been seen completing a
drug deal and he then rammed his car
into stock Lee's police vehicle twice
they engaged in a high-speed chase he
resisted arrest and then allegedly he
reached for a gun though some have
claimed that the gun was planted by
Stockley whose DNA his own DNA was found
on the weapon red pill black as our
expert read pilled realized that race
relations weren't as bad as everybody
said expert was this a setup is there
good reason to protest this verdict no
they're there everything that they are
doing is absolutely animalistic and it's
saddening for me to see because this is
what I hate the most about the
african-american community right now is
that they are constantly rioting they're
constantly acting like animals to no end
you cannot go on a high-speed chase with
a police officer and expect that you
have rights
if you
doing that you are playing with your own
life you they have every right in that
scenario who wasn't just walking down
the street you know and got shot by a
police officer he was engaging in a very
dangerous illegal act and I'm not saying
that he deserved to die but I'm saying
that these protests as a result of him
dying are absolutely ridiculous and it
needs to stop and it's again just shows
you how absolutely warped the media has
African Americans we are killing
ourselves far more you know forget it
you know nobody ever riots when a black
person kills a black person but God
forbid a white person kills a brown she
would not exist if there were riots when
when there's black on black gang
violence or something like that
right be perpetual so just be preparing
but they don't care only if a white
person kills us then we need to act like
animals and so it's disgusting and it's
sad so is your point because the way I
look at this case it may well be the
case that Jason Stockley is a terrible
guy he might have planted that gun he
might he might be a racist for all I
know I'm not sure but the question is in
this trial was justice served and does
does it merit going out and protesting
and breaking windows Jakub area I must
ask you is there a nationwide epidemic
of racist cops killing innocent black
suspects no I don't think so the
statistics do not bear that out in fact
I believe it was Harvard University I
could I could have the University wrong
I can't it can't exactly recall but they
did they did a study where they were
they examine police officers and their
encounters and when they use deadly
force and they were more likely to draw
and shoot a Caucasian male than any
other race ethnicity or even gender they
were because they were so worried about
causing problems like that they were
least likely to draw their weapon
they're more likely to draw their taser
I believe but less likely to draw their
gun on someone who was a minority or a
person of color and it's it's hard to
tell me I read that study that was a
Harvard economist published that there
was a Bayesian analysis that was going
around awhile ago
saying that really there is race
discrimination from white cops to black
suspects
it depends what criteria you're looking
at to with in particular with deadly
force
it may be the case that there's no race
discrimination in respect to black
suspects being pulled over more often it
that may possibly be the case though of
course that has to do with bad
neighborhoods that has to do with
poverty that has to do with the
inner-city so basically one side has
their statistic the other side has their
statistics it does not appear that the
question will be resolved by statistics
so Paul Bois just flat out was justice
served looking at the evidence and
everything that took place I don't see
any evidence that the young man was
murdered by the police officer and what
took place took place I mean I think the
worst thing that the officer did was the
recordings of him what he was saying in
the car but I mean look he was singing
in the car I'm gonna kill this guy or
I'm I'm cleaning up the language a
little bit it was it seemed like he was
out for blood but again the guy had just
hit his car twice yeah I mean you know
look when you're in that situation you
could end up dead and your adrenaline is
pumping at a very very very high rate
and you're just gonna be saying things
that you shouldn't be saying and but
look it's a life or death situation we
have no idea what it's like to be in
that for the police red pill black there
are bad cops there are definitely bad
cops out there and the question is are
we are we being too hard on our police
officers there in these very difficult
situations it's the thin blue line they
protect us from crime they allow us to
live peaceful lives are we being too
hard on the cops or is more oversight
required we are absolutely being too
hard in the cops and the truth of the
matter is is that officers see black
lives and in fact that the media has
kind of facilitated this attack on
police officers is actually going to
cause more harm to black communities
like you said they are more hesitant now
to pull the trigger they're more
hesitant to do their job because they're
afraid of creating this outrage and
becoming the subject of national debate
if they do well all we're doing is
creating a divide between the black and
white community and that divide is very
when it comes to why police officers
think about their what they're doing in
these cities like Chicago I actually
went out of Chicago and met with the
officers in district 11 those are black
officers it's amazing that people have
not figured out that police officers
aren't just white so when you create
this narrative what about these peace
officers that are all black like they
are in Chicago and digital in district
11 which is where you know they have
like the highest rate of crime people
don't think this way what they're
actually doing is creating a harder job
for these people so I'm like staunchly
against this villainizing of police
officers you see that in New York a few
years ago the stop and frisk policy was
criticized by the left they said it was
racist and discriminatory and what they
forgot is in these instances of stop and
frisk it's usually black or Hispanic
officers being called to black or
Hispanic communities and neighborhoods
by black or Hispanic victims to protect
them from very often black or Hispanic
suspects but this isn't this isn't white
cops going in and shooting people race
appeared to have no role in it
whatsoever right and it's just something
that they like I said the me doesn't
talk about they make it according to the
media every police officer is white I
don't understand how people haven't
realized like you said that there are a
lot of black officers and there are a
lot of the span of officers and all of
them and I've spoken to they say the
same thing you know we're the ones
committing the crimes the truth of the
matter is the reason why black people
you know get stopped more and get shots
more by police officers if there are
being shot more by police officers is
because we actually are committing the
most crimes we only represent this much
of the population but if you look at the
crime statistics we represent it
and that's something people don't wanna
talk about they don't want to talk about
the fact that we're creating all these
crimes that were involved in these drug
crimes and these murder rates that were
killing ourselves they only want to talk
and they only want to riot when a white
police officer shoots a black man and do
you know why the media refused to or why
the media insist on perpetuating these
divisive narratives do you know why
because everything is worse on TV that's
why black excellent to have you here we
got to have you back thank you for
coming on
we have his Eminence Baldwin Daily wires
kabiri now it is time to put on my
Stephen Colbert smart glasses and give
the final thought for today's final
thought I'm going to do the unthinkable
I am going to defend Hollywood the
horror the horror specifically I'm going
to defend Darren Aronofsky's movie
mother starring Jennifer Lawrence which
I just saw yesterday I think I'm the
only conservative in the country who
enjoyed mother right wingers have been
excreting this film a writer a National
Review called it the vilest film
Hollywood has ever produced and the
great John Nolte even said that it's an
environmentalist anti-christian anti
human screed now with respect to my
friends in the conservative movement
conservatives are Philistines and they
have missed the rich narrative of this
movie now Jennifer Lawrence and
Aronofsky himself might misunderstand it
too artists often get their own work
wrong but the movie doesn't really make
sense if Lawrence's character is seen as
Mother Earth it makes much more sense if
we realize that Jennifer Lawrence's
character is Satan it is a mill Tony
analogous for Christianity much like
Paradise Lost now the movie is difficult
to watch particularly its depiction of
mankind and the Blessed Sacrament but
that's the point the movie is told from
the point of view of Jennifer Lawrence
who is Satan a mother is a theological a
serious movie that presents a thorough
and disconcerting portrait of the
insidiousness of sin and the
unfathomable magnitude of God's love and
inventiveness we have a sympathetic
Satan character here just like we do in
Paradise Lost and Mother's sympathy
Jennifer Lawrence's characters sympathy
for the devil should startle Christian
audiences out of the sentimental
complacency and shallowness that
Aronofsky assails in his humans it's
worth watch you should go see you that's
our show I'm Michael Mills this is the
Michael Nolt show come back tomorrow
we'll do it all again
[Music]
[Music]